you
[Music]
today I want to jump into talking about
how to use deep learning with just deep
learning in general and how and how
Watson studio can be used to do time
series prediction so my name is Jeremy I
am a data scientist and developer
advocate at IBM Center for open source
data and AI technologies my background
is so I've been with IBM since about to
2015 I started working at the SPARC
Technology Center which was an open
source framework for big data and
machine learning mostly not not really
deep learning and we basically worked on
all aspects of SPARC including client
advocacy developer advocacy public
outreach and then also training people
internally on how to use apache spark
and then basically we expanded that Mis
admission to cover you know most of the
AI technologies out there including
graph databases kubernetes but mostly
the deep learning frameworks so now
we're really into tensorflow pi torch
cafe and and the like our primary
interest is to tensorflow but you know
my background is not computer science I
got a bachelor's in chemical engineering
from Cal across the pond and got a PhD
from UCSF and computational biophysics
where I did mostly protein folding type
calculations drug design calculations
high-performance algorithms for
computing those kinds of things and so I
got you know protein folding definitely
has a big time series aspect to it
there's lots of you know trying to
determine stationarity of time
distributions and detecting convergence
and master equation models and all of
that kind of stuff so I thought it would
be kind of when I heard that you know
neural nets could be used for time
series models I thought oh gosh that
might be kind of a fun thing to try to
get working so but then after that I did
some postdocs at UC Berkeley Lawrence
Berkeley went out to Livermore for a
while where I did more bioinformatics
type applications which kind of got me
into the inside data engineering program
where I joined the private develop sort
of private sector technologies
big data technology or my skill set
around that so that's my background and
you know in general IBM's background
with open source has been you know a
real history of leadership we were the
founding members of the Apache Software
Foundation founding members of the Linux
Software Foundation virtually every
major open source project will have IBM
featured prominently as contributors so
we we definitely are proud of that
heritage probably more proud of it than
most large tech firms and so we're we've
been doing open source for quite some
time and our particular group is
completely dedicated to open source so
when we say open source data and AI
technologies we're talking about all the
open source frameworks primarily and
then we're also talking about you know
the open source when we say open source
data we're talking about data that that
is open and freely available has good
governance and also formats file formats
such as the Onix format which we'll be
talking about maybe in the next month or
so and in future talks but our our goal
here is just to make AI solutions easier
to create deploy and manage in the
enterprise and as I mentioned this is
kind of a retooling of the SPARC
technology center for those of you who
may be familiar with ESD see it was
quite well known for its contributions
in the open source community but the the
things that we the things that we're
going to talk about today we've got this
whole framework we're gonna talk about
the model asset exchange fabric for deep
learning and then the the more
exploratory process of of analyzing data
so I just want to blow this up a little
bit and then you can see so we've got
lots of frameworks here that we're
concerned about but really you know the
Watson studio environment really is
built on top of Jupiter and I'm guessing
just a quick show of hands who uses
Jupiter maybe daily or yeah okay so
basically the Watson studio is just is
just a Jupiter front-end that connects
to various remote kernels cloud-hosted
kernels various environments so you can
connect to a spark environment
connect to a gpu-accelerated environment
you can connect to s3 you can connect to
all kinds of remote clusters but it
still has that Jupiter environment that
you're working in so it's quite quite
nice and quite quite natural even though
you're working in significantly
different hardware space the front end
is very familiar to you so the so so
these are these are the the areas that
we're gonna be working on the there are
two main projects at code a is concerned
with and one is the model asset exchange
and I'd really encourage you to check
this out because even when we started
this we didn't realize how far along the
model zoos were that are out there how
many freely available perfectly open
neural network models that are just
ready to go are out there that you can
that you can run so you basically what
we did is we went and we vetted a whole
series of models ooz provided by all the
open source frameworks we made sure that
the data was had good provenance that
you could use it in commercial
applications you didn't have to just use
it for research applications you didn't
have to do any special permissions
around the data that was used to train
the model made sure the code that we was
properly vetted and had the right
licensing and all of that so you can
just grab these things and run with them
but it also is a just a great tour of
what these neural networks are capable
of and of course we've seen we've seen
some image detection models and some
other things you can't quite see some of
these but we've got a facial edge facial
age estimator weather forecaster which
is actually a version of what we're
talking about but what the important
thing to remember is that these are all
pre trained models so you don't have to
deal with the training aspect of it you
just you know feature so for example we
have something called object detector it
has I don't know on the order of
hundreds of objects that it's trained on
so you don't need to do any training to
get those to work so that's what's nice
about it we tried to fix some
I had some transferability already
facial age estimator for example you
know as long as you're not trying to
estimate the age of let's say cats or
something this is going to work pretty
robustly for for a lot of examples so so
you don't need to do any retraining and
you can get a very quick sense of how
these models perform the kinds of tasks
that they can carry out for example we
get image caption generator and some
other ones that are quite nice you can
deploy them on our API framework and
then just do make rest calls or you can
go to the github and download download
the download the source code and compile
the docker image and then just run the
docker container from from wherever you
like and and so it's all completely free
and and completely open until you start
using the web service or something like
that I can't remember but so so those
are for the the pre-trained the pre
train models is the model asset exchange
and then these are all the stats there
are some also some patterns that are
related to it now for trainable models
you have to have a slightly more complex
framework because it's still the same
idea where you're going to want to
deploy this now now it's actually
slightly lean more towards deploying on
remote hardware that way it can spin up
a GPU instance somewhere remotely so
this has a little bit more machinery
around keeping track of your
asynchronous job requests and job
monitoring and all that kind of stuff
but the same idea is there these you can
deploy this and using kubernetes and
then you have a remote container sitting
on one of our hosted GPU instances and
then you can just spin it up for the
training and then spin it back down so
and this is getting to the point now or
will be supporting slightly more
sophisticated environments like [ __ ]
Avadh which has like allows for parallel
training using MPI and some other and I
think some other frameworks we're gonna
be like and just getting into this Onix
format that we're gonna be learning a
little bit more about in the near future
so I'm looking forward
about that but so this is two frameworks
but the two frameworks that are really
useful when you either know what you're
you know what the task is and you you
feel like you've got a network that's
trained or you know that you need to
train a network but you you don't you're
not really experimenting with the
architecture of the network or anything
like that so you just know that you've
got a network and you just need to
retrain it on
for example facial age estimator just
retrain it on cats if you want to
estimate cat ages but you know there's
still a large grouping of problems that
don't that don't fall into that you
don't know what the best architecture is
you don't you don't even really know
what the data set might be which we
spend a fair amount of time talking
about explain ability and which features
are relevant for describing
creditworthiness for example and it
takes a little time noodling that out
before before you can just spin up an
API and start running sort of for these
production level containers to train
your code so really if you look at this
you know this workflow you've got
execution and consumption which is
really the max in the fiddle and then
you know providing API s or some
engineering solution that you have
in-house and those are probably you know
well-worn paths within your company or
something that's well understood but
there's this huge section of discovery
where you still you you got to find the
model you got to get the code you got to
test it you got to verify it kind of do
all that stuff so you're back really
back to working in your notebook
environment or your know you're doing
some exploratory modeling and what
happens when you do this if you want to
do this with a neural network you're
gonna you're gonna even within NIST
you're waiting awhile to get this thing
trained right you even know what the
smallest interesting neural network that
you can come up with you're really
pushing the resources of your laptop or
your desktop or whatever it is and maybe
I want to go out and buy a GPU
node right away so this is the kind of
thing that we encourage you to you know
try to try to spin up a gpu-accelerated
studio instance for example and then
you've got immediate access to to a GPU
node same thing with the spark cluster
you can have immediate access to a spark
cluster rather than wait waiting until
you outgrow your single node machine so
it's a good good place good sandbox for
that kind of thing and so this is what
the environment looks like it's
basically it looks like a jupiter
notebook has just got it's just got some
additional collaborative features and
things like that so so this is a typical
interface and it does the same kind of
inputs and outputs that you would expect
if you know it does the Panda Slyke
output of the data frame and this also
just just to show you rather than do a
live demo I just wanted to throw up a
couple screenshots so you can see what
the notebook looks like rather than
scroll through through the notebook I
did also want to point out that there
are some there's a little bit of
boilerplate code that allows you to
connect to a remote cloud storage
instance and that's about that's about
the only you know complexity that's
added really that's the only time you
see anything under the covers when
you're running on these Jupiter
notebooks so let's just take a step back
and kind of remind ourselves what a
neural network is and we can talk about
now we can just kind of okay this is the
neural network then we're going to be
using for time series modeling this is
one recommended recommended architecture
so we're just gonna I'm just going to
walk through you know how that how this
is going to look and in order to do that
we kind of got to jump back a little bit
and understand what what a neuron is and
so a neuron really is these you've got
these features that come in you add them
up with a set of linear weights you get
this x times W this is a vector
operation here plus a bias term and that
gives you the Z term and that's just
this superposition of all these inputs
right this is just the multiplication
addition operation then that goes into
something called an
activation function this would be the
neuron and this lights up in various
ways probably the best way to think
about it is this logistic or hyperbolic
tangent where it's basically a switch it
hits some threshold and it lights up
right it's either on or it's off that's
that's the the historical way that we've
thought about neurons in the context of
neural networks numerically speaking
most of these most of these terms are
used the rail u the rectified linear
units just because it has better
numerical properties so all the ones
that we're using here have the rectified
linear unit so and you know we can put
all these together to form a dense layer
so we've got layer one here and these
you know basically you can think you can
you know don't don't worry about the
neurons here just think about the arrows
coming out those arrows are numbers
those numbers are getting piped into
another layer and that other layer is
being all the numbers are being added up
using that add addition multiplication
operation and then an activation
function transforms that into some
switching value but the important thing
to remember is that these really these
neural networks are always assembled in
these layers and the layers really only
connect to the next layer or the
previous layer so when we say a densely
connected layer this is always really
going to be the way it's done it's just
this sort of and and and you probably
the best way to think about this is just
as some orderly arrangement of
parameters to form some complex
nonlinear function that you're going to
fit data to really and then at the end
of the day you've just got a function
that you you've got a function and
you've got values and you want to just
fit to fit the function to that so this
is the classic M nest model as we said
we've seen almost endless examples of
image processing this is really a very
mature field at this point in in the
neural network field so but this is you
know this is about as simple as a simple
a
as a useful Network as we can possibly
construct but it's useful to review it
or maybe to see it for the first time so
you can understand how how these the
philosophy behind these things so you've
got basically you've got an input and
you've got an output so the input is
this image this image is just this list
of pixels the pixels is unwrapped so
there's actually 28 by 28 pixels that's
unwrapped into a feature vector of 784
values each one has each one has a value
that's fed into the first layer which is
the input layer and the number of input
layers matches the number of values and
those get piped in and then we have a
whole series of fully connected networks
and you can be clever about whether they
get bigger or bigger or smaller or how
deep they are and all that kind of
clever stuff to get the best
architecture and there's also lots of
complexities that we really don't need
to go into here about creating
convolution layers and things like that
that are more particular to image
processing so there's a lot of really
clever image processing tricks that go
into these that go into these image
networks that were we we won't really
need to cover here but this is a basic
idea so you pipe in this vector output
this has you know 10 neurons you know if
you'd make the top one as one the last
one is 0 then if the seventh neuron has
the highest value or lights up the most
then we would identify the output as
recommending that the image corresponds
to number 7 so that's the it's a
classifier basically returns the
classification output so really I mean
and and even the optimizations for
classifiers are slightly different than
something that produces a floating-point
number so the fact that we're dealing
with floating point number in time
series is actually kind of a unique
aspect to the neural network most of the
tasks in neural networks are
classification tasks not you know
floating point predictions so the sort
of the next wrinkle to this is the
recurrent neural
work and this usually represented this
way which is super confusing anytime I
see recursion I always get confused
because I wrote my thesis in Fortran
I always unroll loops so I recursion I
think is a unnecessary you know
unnecessary abbreviation of notation but
here we have here we can actually unroll
these loops here you can you can't
actually recurse this as often as you
like in practice you do unroll these
loops a finite number of times the way
that they're the way they're constructed
so the idea here though is that you have
an input and this neuron gets modified
it has the the neuron now has an
internal state that gets modified every
time you feed it an input and then what
you do is you feed it the next input the
next input being the same feature but a
different step in time right so now it
explicitly understands that the next
thing that's happening is connected to
the previous state so it has to maintain
a memory state in order to process that
information so then repeat we put we
pipe this xn modifies the state goes and
now the neuron is in a new state the new
state is and then it produces an output
the new neuron is the same I mean it's
the same neuron but a new state is is
fed a new value it modifies the state
and then also produces a new output so
it connects previous events it has a
memory of previous events so the place
where this really shines has
historically been language processing
because phrases you know words are
strung together in a meaningful way and
each word that follows the next word is
connected to the previous word in some
way and so and so this is in this is a
again with time series is almost kind of
a a sideshow compared to the work that's
been done in language processing so this
is the this is the famous LS TM neuron
there are a few there's a couple there's
one called the gated recurrent unit
which is slightly more
has fewer parameters and is thought to
have better performance characteristics
for whatever reason you see this one
much more frequently I just think it's
better understood and it has lots and
lots of internal parameters the idea
being again that it has basically the
capacity to remember the important
things forget the unimportant things and
you know depending on the interval of
training it has capacity to you know
keep keep the keep the notion of the
previous time step having a stronger
influence on the state then you know
maybe five states back and things like
that all of that is thought to be
contained in this pretty complex neuron
but at the end of the day this is a
neuron that produces an output and
returns a state right and so this is how
it's connected now it's just got two
parameters that sort of correspond to
its state and they're sort of pipe
through the LS TM you know in in various
ways so so now you can now you can feed
your time series in and then have it
return a time series you can have a time
series of a different length go in and
have a different time series the time
series going in can be of different
lengths in the time series going out you
can call it multiple times and have it
return multiple states and in an
arbitrary way so you're not constrained
in that way if you depending on the
architecture that you use so this is the
this is the encoder decoder multivariate
time so this is modified from a blog in
a text that's been written a very very
nice blog series and book and we're just
sort of modifying it slightly and here
we just have this whole set of inputs
we're missing all these fully connected
arrows B just because it makes the
slides so busy but the at the end of the
day you have an input and an output
you've got a feature vector now with
eight values and fourteen time steps so
that means that these input values here
there's going to be eight input X's and
each one of those X's
is gonna have 14 times steps associated
with it two weeks worth of data in this
case that's going to that's going to
feed into something called an LS TM
encoder and what's happening here these
are the LS TM neurons right here this
column here and then you have something
called the repeat vector which just hits
that LS TM an arbitrary number of times
in this case seven days and that's going
to produce a time series now not a 14
days but of seven days in length so if
you just look at this first if you just
look at this first Network here this in
principle could just be its own
generative Network right you could you
know there's that you give it 14 days
where the data makes a prediction for
for seven days but what happens is that
this is actually thought of more as an
internal representation of the data
so they there's something called how
many people are familiar with an
autoencoder okay so this is sort of an
sort of the idea behind an autoencoder
what you do is you have a neural network
with inputs and then you reproduce those
inputs with the output and then you let
the neural network kind of morph the
data into some clever representation of
the data in it somewhere in the middle
and it's thought that that
representation somewhere in the middle
is is a meaningful way of encoding the
data and so that's what's happening here
we're pushing it through this neural
network there's an output at the end
that we have to fit the data to but
you're giving it some wiggle room and
allowing you know the entropy of these
parameters to to produce some really
interesting representation of the data
that can then be more effectively
decoded and then rigidify dand and
pumped into the fitting process so
that's what's happening here where we
were just we're just doing an encoding
process so so we've created this encoded
time series now now we're going to pipe
that through another LS TM and that's
just going to be the decoding process
well this is all the time series stuff
is happening right at the beginning and
then out the output of that gets piped
into this time distributed
time distributed dense layer which is
really just a way of processing that
data so it's each time each time slice
is now a dense neural network so really
this whole temporal aspect is not so
much captured here it's just sort of
pumped right into these dints neural
networks and this is kind of a little
bit more like a kind of a static like
you instead of saying that this is a
time series is just saying these are
seven pieces of data that's let's push
through that and try to try to make a
prediction with that and then it's ghost
goes to this hundred by seven hundred by
seven neurons and then that eventually
goes to this last dense time distributed
output layer which is two by seven
neurons which get which means we're
predicting to two variables to two
variables with with eight input so we've
got multivariate inputs and and multi
multivariate outputs so that's that's
that's that's the architecture that we
think will turn out to be the most
generalizable sort of solve the majority
of your problems you just kind of adjust
the size of the networks and things like
that
and should be able to should be able to
get good prediction properties so so so
here's just an example some of the some
of the some of the cells that are that
are in that are in Watson studio or the
just a network here and this is what it
looks like in Kerris so you add an LS TM
with two hundred two hundred nodes okay
we remember that we get the relative
activation layer okay remember that and
then at the repeat vector with the
number of outputs being set to seven and
then add the other LS TM layer and then
the time distributed one hundred node
layer along with the time distributed
two node layer and and then use the atom
optimizer and yeah you don't you don't
need to use a you know cross entropy as
the loss here because we're actually
going back to good old-fashioned
floating-point fitting rather than
trying to do Caterpie categorization so
and in this we run this for about 50
epics
and this is you know there's only a
thousand examples in this test set but
they're you know it's it's running at a
decent clip the six millisecond per per
step and I think this whole whole thing
takes about a minute to run so and again
if if you ever get a chance to use this
model summary this is great way to do a
sanity check and again you've got the
layers notice the time distributed layer
is the seven by 100 so it's got a
hundred knows but there's seven by 100
of those nodes because it's a time
distributed layer produces all
prediction for a seven series and then
and then the last one it's got the two
two by seven III think you know the
interesting thing here is we got a
thousand data points but we have a half
a million parameters and the it's just
this you know there's this there's lots
of articles on this but there is it
seems like an unreasonable task to
expect it to work well right but a lot
of it is because of the entropy the
construction the fact that it kind of
self regularizes the way it's built so
so so so even you could do studies to
see if it's over fit and things like
that but it is the way that the the fact
that you any node can point to any other
node it introduces this degeneracy in
the nodes that that allows these thing
neural networks to perform well even
when there's more much more parameters
than than data in many cases so but you
you you you might want to take a look at
that you might want to evaluate so we
really jump into the evaluation of the
fitness of the model here we're just
saying hey we're just hooked up the
plumbing that we think this is a good
network maybe when we tried this one out
and so this is just an example of what
the input data looks like just to mostly
just to give you a sanity checked you
know there's 14 14 data points for the
input this is energy data so it's not
particularly interesting data set but
you know it could be substituted with
any any other data set and certainly
much larger ones so and so this is the
actual data and the predicted data so it
does well on one doesn't looks like it
needs a little bit of work on the other
one and that that's basically it that's
the
that's how you might go about hooking
this up and so now really the the easy
part is hooking it up of course and then
the hard part is is doing the analytics
and making sure you've got high quality
data and good performance
characteristics so we didn't really we
didn't really get into that too much
here so with that I guess I'll wrap up
just a little bit earlier and definitely
really want to encourage you to try out
the max models on the model exchange
site also check out our developer
website we've got lots of we've got lots
of really great free work resources on
on the developer IBM comm lots of great
patterns lots of great examples and lots
of great blogs so with that I guess I
can wrap up and answer any questions you
might have I could could you go back a
few slides where you kind of had the
code and you listed the the batch size
and the app box and stuff yeah yeah why
did you choose the batch size of 16 May
I don't see anything obvious I'm just
curious why your thought process on that
yeah actually I didn't choose that one
okay yeah I didn't I didn't choose I did
this didn't require a lot of tuning I
mean the whole thing trained in under a
minute so so we could fiddle with that
and see see what happens even the number
of a box I didn't adjust
I just took 50 out of the box and ran
with it and seemed to a good performance
I really didn't evaluate performance on
this and in turn predictive performance
mostly it was just to you know making
sure that we just wanted actually the
big question was can we do this on a
multivariate time series is it even
possible because of the way the networks
are constructed typically the I it's a
it's a univariate output they say it can
be the univariate output can be a that
univariate output it could be a vector
but in fact it really can be a extra
note so that was really the thing that
we were more concerned with but but yeah
so yeah I can I can I can fiddle with
that
see what effects yeah
[Music]